[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce numéro
spécial du 7 8 et co consacrée à la
crise sanitaire et aux conséquences
économiques dans le département des
yvelines
[Musique]
c'est un secteur impacté par cette crise
sanitaire mais elle résiste un certains
commerces ont l'autorisation de rester
ouverts pendant le confinement ils se
sont organisés on était accompagné
notamment par saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération a mis en place plusieurs
dispositifs pour soutenir ces
commerçants pour en parler valérie
raffalli chargé de mission du commerce
de saint quentin en yvelines bonjour
bonjour alors est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer quels dispositifs ont été
mis en place par saint quentin en
yvelines alors déjà vous avez dit
l'entraîneur introduction je pense que
c'est important de rappeler chiffres
qu'on à certains commerçants son
territoire sont effectivement ouvert
pour vous donner une idée on a neuf
cents commerçants sur le territoire on
estime qu on a à peu près un tiers
d'entre eux qui sont actuellement
ouverts voilà donc ça c'est pour poser
un petit peu la base de travail est donc
aujourd'hui les outils de que ce qui a
mis en place sa tiennent essentiellement
autour d'une page internet dédiée aux
commerçants dans laquelle ces
commerçants vont pouvoir trouver de deux
types d'appui anna puisqu'il est d'abord
technique c'est à dire qu'on a mis un
focus sur les principales aides
auxquelles ils ont droit
qu'elles soient gouvernementales
régional etc tous a résumé dans un petit
guide qu'il faut être téléchargeable à
partir de ce site
et puis on a mis également en place tout
un panel je dirais d'outils plus de
promotions leur permettant de
communiquer de mettre en avant leurs
offres dans cette période difficile
donc ça tient déjà pour commencer sur
une cartographie interactive sur
laquelle on a à peu près 200 80
commerçants de recenser alors 280
commerçants et producteurs parce que nos
amis agriculteurs nous ont rejoints dans
ce dans ce mouvement donc sont également
référencés
pour vous donner une idée on a à peu
près dix mille vue sur cette cette
cartographie interactive
alors c'est un outil qu'on donne à
combler à disposition d
merci c'est à dire que nous on a
alimenté mais eux peuvent très bien
compléter leur fiche précise et des
horaires des services qu'ils auraient
mis en place depuis donc voilà c'est
vraiment un outil qui l'aurait qu'il
aurait offert les décideurs d'informer
les saint quentinois qu'ils ont accès à
ces commerçants c'est sain exactement et
puis alors non seulement qu'ils ont
accès à ces commerces mais d'y préciser
les horaires d'ouverture parce que on le
verra beaucoup de ces commerçants se
sont adaptés en changeant leurs horaires
et puis si certains font du dry de la
livraison etc
voilà le deuxième outil qu'on a alors
relayé parce que nous n'avons pas
initiatives ont trouvé cet outil
particulièrement adapté la problématique
c'est la mise en place de bons d'achat
qui permettent aux saint quentinois
d'ores et déjà de prépayer je dirais de
réserver des prestations ou des produits
avec un ticket moyen
ce qui permet aux commerçants de
bénéficier d'ores et déjà de trésorerie
voilà ça permet c'est dans une démarche
solidaire
ça permet aux commerçants de recevoir un
petit peu d'argent dans ces périodes
difficiles
et enfin le troisième outil qu'on a mis
en place et qui remporte un gros succès
c'est ce groupe facebook ce qui soutient
ces commerçants et là je regardais
encore les chiffres ce matin on en est à
2700 membres en l'espace d'une dizaine
de jours
alors dans ce site on retrouve dans ce
groupe facebook on retrouve non
seulement des commerçants qui là encore
se sont accaparés cet outil pour y
mettre à l'honneur leurs nouveaux
horaires leurs prestations etc
on s'aperçut également que c'est un
outil clé saint quentinois ont se sont
accaparés pour s'échanger des bouquiaux
si je puis dire de recommander leur l'a
vu notamment de pâques de recommander le
broc faux kolatier indépendant etc
un dernier mot valérie raffalli comment
se sentent les commerçants vous avez des
échanges vous lançait d'ailleurs eu
aussi une enquête auprès des commerçants
de saint quentin en yvelines où et
comment ils se sentent qu'elles sont la
principale inquiétude disons je dirais
que dans un premier temps lorsqu'on les
a
et au premier jour honnêtement il y
avait un sentiment les sentais un petit
peu abasourdi carreau et puis très vite
on a été agréablement surpris par leur
capacité d'adaptation et donc la plupart
d'entre premièrement ont mis en place
des mesures les gestes barrière aussi
bien pour leurs salariés que ''pour
cliente m
très vite également ils ont mis en place
des services de livraison j'y reviens ou
de drive certains ça a été l'opportunité
pour eux de se lancer dans le e-commerce
ou du moins un minimum sur des réseaux
sociaux
voilà donc la livraison c'est par
exemple 50 % de plus sur le territoire
relier à travers des leurs fichiers
clients ou les réseaux sociaux c'est 60%
d'entre eux en ont mis en place cette
mesure dont qui sont après un petit
moment
normal très compréhensif d'abattement et
se sont très vite remis en question et
ont fait preuve de réactivité
d'ingéniosité et justement nous on
essaie de les accompagner au mieux pour
ça se débloque pas encore plus avant et
après j'insiste ouais merci
valérie raffalli pour ses explications
je rappelle que vous êtes chargé de
mission et aux commerçants à saint
quentin en yvelines et illustrations de
cette situation avec le saveurs des
comptoirs 1 basée à voisins le
bretonneux l'activité de l'enseignant
spécialisé dans la vente de café et de
thé se poursuit avec des adaptations par
rapport à la situation actuelle
les explications avec wilfrid richy et
patrick jacques de dixmude pas d'accès
direct à la boutique mais un retrait
juste devant la porte principale un
système de drive improvisé afin de
permettre un maintien de l'activité
depuis le début du confinement
l'enseigne saveurs des comptoirs s'est
adapté et recentrer sur l'activité de
vente de thé et de café
j'avais un gros doute sur le fait que ce
soit ouvert mais bon après je me dis que
le café c'est quand même un produit de
première nécessité donc pourquoi pas
j'ai tenté ma chance
étant moi-même artisans sur saint
quentin en yvelines
je me dois de faire travailler d'autres
confrères artisans aux commerçants donc
c'est pour ça aussi que je viens dans
ces petites structures là déjà on l'a
fait pour nos clients ensuite on l'a
fait parce que il faut il faut que la
boutique puisse tourner on a déménagé
cette année l'année dernière ça fait un
peu plus de six mois
donc c'était un gros projet avec des
gros enjeux donc aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on assure la pérennité de notre
entreprise
le manque à gagner est d'ores et déjà
importants avec un chiffre d'affaires
divisé par deux depuis trois semaines
est ce que certain c'est que d'une part
on n'a pas perdu une partie notre notre
clientèle toute la clientèle qui vient
notamment de de gérer 2
d'assez loin pas forcément la proximité
même de la boutique qui ne peut plus
dépasser aujourd'hui la clientèle
d'entreprises qui ne va plus au bureau
malgré tout les dirigeants ont décidé de
limiter les recours aux aides mises en
place par l'état notamment les reports
de charges et une seule salariée est
aujourd'hui en chômage partiel
c'est sûr que par contre la reprise
risque d'être compliqué c'est un peu le
jir elle pleut l'inconnu dans cette
histoire c'est comment voilà comment le
leur tour gérait le dégonflement va
là-bas ce passé mais c'est sûr que ça
aura des impacts économiques à moyen
terme puisque tout l'argent qu'ils ne
rendent pas aujourd'hui dans les
entreprises
et puis chez les chez les particuliers
forcément ne se retrouvera pas sur le
sur l'économie demain donc c'est sûr que
ça sera la fin d'année 2000 2020 sera
forcément plus compliqué à la demande du
gouvernement et pour répondre aux
besoins croissants des hôpitaux
un consortium de quatre industriels
français réunissant air liquide ps à
schneider electric et valeo a été
constituée fin mars pour produire 10
mille respirateur en 50 jours
pour l'équipementier automobile valeo
dont l'un de ses sites en france est
implanté à la verrière il s'agit de
mettre à profit ses compétences
spécifiques dans les systèmes thermiques
mais pas uniquement
écoutez françois bord de l'un des
responsables du site saint quentinois de
valeo et aux et dont on le côtoie
consortium avec notre expérience en
achats approvisionnements en r&d
recherche et développement tout ce qui
est électronique ou mécanique et en
production systèmes de production au
total valeo il ya une vingtaine de
personnes qui supportent ce consortium
dans cette première phase d'étude et
d'approvisionnement et on va commencer
cette semaine faire de la production
d'appareils d'augmenter la production
et là on a fait appel au volontariat
pour elle et sur le site d'air liquide
produire des appareils montée des
appareils et on est en train de faire un
appel au volant paris
ça va démarrer cette semaine ce week-end
pour la partie mon potager formation est
identique chez les autres partenaires
les trois partenaires que sont edf a
gelé d'air et valeo c'est d'abord une
grande fierté pour pour tous les membres
valeo de participer à cette aventure est
pour moi une bonne surprise de voir
combien sont motivés tous les gens qui
touchent de près ou de loin ce projet et
qu'ils veulent ou qu'ils proposent
d'apporter leur aide leur support et de
façon très dynamique et très réactif
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire et
la première allocution du président de
la république emmanuel macron le groupe
renault s'organise pour répondre aux
besoins en matériel médical
plusieurs projets sont engagés la
production de visière pour les
personnels soignants et la participation
à la conception de respirateurs dans ces
deux projets le technocentre de
guyancourt est pleinement engagé regarde
et de la recherche et développement
automobile à la production de matériel
médical
le technocentre renault de guyancourt
s'est adapté à la crise sanitaire du coc
vide dix neuf plus d'une centaine de
collaborateurs de ce site sont mobilisés
sur plusieurs projets notamment la
production de 10 hier destiné au
personnel soignant
on a l'ensemble de nos les leçons de
production par impression 3d qui sont
mobilisés pour produire des supports de
ville hier à destination des soignants
font des signes plutôt ces masques là
pour les chaudières là pour le personnel
soignant que c'est vraiment des matières
qui sont compatibles avec les protocoles
d'options 700 visière ont déjà été
produites sur les sites de guyancourt
flins et à maubeuge depuis le début de
la semaine un moule a été conceptualisée
pour produire en grandes séries objectif
4000 visière minimum par semaine
c'est un moule qui permet de sortir une
pièce avec une cadence très élevée qu'on
injecte en fait un plastique dans un
moule en métal pouvoir sortir à la suite
très rapidement donc ça permet de passer
ce qu'on veut imprimer en 3d sur une
machine vous allez pouvoir par exemple
sur 24 heures sur les sur des matières
qui sont durs compatibles sortir 60
unités alors que là on va pouvoir avoir
une capacité une vitesse de production
bien supérieure et en même temps
linéaire imprimante 3d pour la
fabrication kiev à destination des
respirateurs c'est l'autre activité du
technocentre dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire la participation à la
conception de respirateurs à travers
deux projets avec un consortium
industriel autour de michelin du cea et
de stmicroelectronics et d'une
initiative d'ingénieur à paris sur ces
deux premiers là on apporte des
compétences en conception des
compétences achats des compétences
logistique supply chain réalisation
prototype également
et industriels le projet qui est le plus
avancé aujourd'hui on envisage une mise
en production vraiment de temps avec une
production de faim sans respirateur
jours donc une part qui serait né à
réaliser pour l'instant cessé d études
que nous avons en cours au technocentre
cette situation est inédite une
véritable organisation industrielle
collaborative pour participer à la lutte
contre le coronavirus
restons à saint quentin en yvelines avec
cette start up qui portent l'étendard de
la french tech paris saclay ce qui
éloigne portal n'est pas épargné par
cette crise mais face à cette situation
elle en profite pour innover en
organisant des réunions en réalité
virtuelle entre les différents
collaborateurs confinés à leur domicile
immersion dans leurs bureaux virtuels
premier format en plus ou moins immersif
numérique
c'est une méthode innovante de travail
collaboratif en pleine période de
confinement des réunions d'entreprises
en réalité virtuelle spécialisée sur
cette technologie
la start-up minimes antenne sky one
porte à la mise en place cette nouvelle
organisation
on a des contenus qu'on s'est fait
rendre réseau conseille d'utiliser un
casque et même sur pc on s'est dit allez
on va essayer dans quelques jours
finalement on a repris notre base de
code et on a intégré une sorte d'outil
qui nous permet de nous rencontrer en
val était virtuelle dans un bureau
virtuel
les collaborateurs sont équipés d'un
casque de réalité virtuelle
chacun chez soi ils sont en immersion
des échanges facilités et quasi
naturelle déjà on est plus fluide
qu'avec du zoo ou du skype parce qu'on
met pas la vidéo on n'en aurait que le
son et des positions d'objets 3d
en termes d'usagés finalement c'est
devenu très naturel c'est ça qui est
quand même surprenant
on s'est dit on va le tester on sait pas
du tout ce que ça va donner et on s'est
retrouvé à retrouver mes mimiques de
chacun les tout ce qu'est gestuelle en
fait un peu spécifique à chaque personne
on voulait retrouver dedans développé
depuis le début du confinement cette
solution est utilisé uniquement pour
l'activité de sky one portal une phase
d'expérimentation avant peut-être de la
commercialiser on ne sait pas possible
on va déjà voir un petit peu l'intérêt
donc on va communiquer un petit peu sur
le réseau sur ce type d' usage et si
effectivement sans qu'il y ait une
demande on sera ravi effectivement de
proposer quelque chose qui soit un peu
plus packagées que que ce qui est
aujourd'hui pour l'instant à l'état de
prototype spécialisé dans les secteurs
du divertissement de l'événementiel et
du service aux industries cette start up
est impacté par cette crise plusieurs
mesures du gouvernement ont pu être
déclenchées
objectif avoir une visible
dit et sur le maintien de la trésorerie
d'ici à la fin de l'année
[Musique]
le tourisme l'hôtellerie la restauration
mais aussi l'industrie des secteurs
impactés par cette crise sanitaire et
économique dans le département des
yvelines avec nous gérard bacheliers
bonjour bonjour président de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie des yvelines
alors avec vous est ce qu'on peut faire
un point sur la situation économique
dans le département
un mois après le début du confinement la
situation économique dans le département
donc tu es est toujours aussi compliqué
bien sûr vous l'avez dire les
restaurants hôtels restent fermés donc
je peux vous donner quelques chiffres
par rapport aux autres chômage partiel à
l'utilisation des fonds de solidarité
puisque nous avons dix sept mille
établissements donc qui en demandait le
chômage partiel qui représente à peu
près de 112 1722 salariés c'est à peu
près 50 % des établissements de du des
yvelines donc c'est quand même à un
point important avec bien sûr
restauration hôtellerie qui sont les
plus marquées et après bien sûr la
l'industrie la métallerie la
construction concernant le fonds de
solidarité vous l'avez évoqué il ya des
fonds sont des fonds de solidarité pour
notamment les petites entreprises les
indépendants les commerçants ça aussi
c'est très utilisé par les acteurs
yvelinois c'est utiliser mais pas
suffisamment utilisé puisque il y a eu
donc 7200 paiement ce qui représente à
peu près pour une moyenne de 1350 euros
par part paiement et c'est largement
insuffisant au niveau de l'île de france
d'ailleurs par rapport à d'autres
régions
donc on incite largement les entreprises
qui peuvent y avoir droit à l'utiliser
d'autant plus que ce système de fonds de
solidarité va être un peu plus élargie
dans la loi de finances rectificative
qui est en discussion actuellement il ya
quand même des évolutions importantes
qui sont apportées justement à ce fonds
de solidarité
il faut vraiment que les entreprises
profite de cette de ceux de ce
dispositif sur la situation économique
aussi on peut parler malheureusement de
certaines défaillances d'entreprises ou
pas du tout c'est pas encore le cas pour
l'instant on n'a pas beaucoup d'éléments
sur les défaillances d'entreprises je
pense qu'on le verra après cela la crise
sanitaire
par contre ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que il y a en tout cas les informations
que j'ai c'est qu'il ya déjà des
entreprises qui ont décidé d'arrêter
carrément donc liquide liquidations
directes sans procédure donc ça c'est un
élément quand même important ça veut
dire qu'on en a qui baissent les bras et
qui abandonnent
et puis depuis le début de la crise vous
avez mis en place une plate forme
téléphonique d'urgence pour les
entreprises est ce que vous avez mis
depuis d'autres dispositifs en place
oui alors cette plateforme a reçu dix
sept mille sollicitations et nous avons
mis deux deux outils supplémentaires
c'est une plateforme qui s'appelle cci
entraide qui permet justement des
échanges de solidarité et de
complémentarité entre entreprises dans
les entreprises peuvent faire des offres
où certains recherchent des produits
donc ça permet justement d'avoir des
échanges solidaires entre entreprises
dans cette situation difficile mais ça
peut je pense perdurer par la suite et
je l'espère il ya aussi donc une autre
bâton quand on a mis en place ce qui
s'appelle mais commerce à domicile qui
permet justement de référence et les
commerces qui ont mis en place des
livraisons à domicile et donc cette
ville dans les yvelines donc ont choisi
ce système c'est poissy mantes la jolie
les mureaux maurepas houdan camplong
sainte honorine andrésy voilà donc c'est
une plateforme qui permet justement
d'aider les commerces de centre-ville
dans leur livraison à domicile un
dernier mot gerra bacheliers le
président de la république emmanuel
macron a annoncé à un début de
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai
prochain comment vous imaginez cette
relance économique
et est-ce qu'il va pas avoir
on va pas constaté une rupture avec
l'ancien modèle économique d'avant crise
we7 cette relance elle va être
progressive à être progressif tout
simplement parce qu'il ya quelques gérer
filière qui vont démarrer comme le
bâtiment les travaux publics qui vont
démarrer assez vite avant la fin du mois
d'avril
mais bon les difficultés qui vient voir
bien sûr ces deux d'avoir tous les
éléments sanitaires nécessaires pour
justement permettre à ces entreprises de
travailler c'est-à-dire des masques des
blues tout ce qui est nécessaire
et puis une nouvelle organisation du
travail aussi pour les entreprises du
bâtiment et des travaux publics qui va
justement créé un surcoût pour ces
entreprises et ce surcoût va se
retrouver bien sûr dans leurs devis et
dans leurs propositions
c'est évident donc c'est un surcoût qui
va être nécessaire et d'autres
entreprises repartent comme les
jardineries actuellement donc qui
repartaient il faut savoir que
jardinerie c'est entre mars et juin
qu'ils font le maximum de leur chiffre
d'affaires
mais bien sûr par la suite j'irai à plus
long terme qu'il faut penser à une
relocalisation un autre modèle de
fonctionnement de l'industrie de
l'économie sur nos territoires
il faut profiter justement de ce qui
s'est passé jusqu'à maintenant c'est à
dire de la livraison à domicile des
circuits courts d'une utilisation un peu
plus importante de tout ce qui est de
tout le numérique donc et ça il faut il
faut que ça dure je pense qu'il faut que
ça continue et aussi des bons exemples
de solidarité entre entreprises puisque
on voit que air liquide renault peugeot
et valeo travailler ensemble pour les
pour les respirateurs mais aussi
d'autres entreprises profitent de cette
phase pour aider justement le public et
pour givet renouveler un petit peu leur
leur façon de fonctionner donc j'espère
que cette solidarité grandes entreprises
petites entreprises va durer sur le
territoire qu'on aura un peu plus de
sous traitants locaux
et puis aussi que tout ce qui est lié
aux circuits courts va perdurer
par la suite merci gérard bacheliers
pour ce décryptage vous en prie
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie
yvelines et cette crise cette crise
économique est sans précédent depuis le
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
selon les dernières estimations de la
croissance
elles devraient baisser 1 2 8 % en 2020
face à cette situation le gouvernement a
décidé de renforcer son plan d'urgence
économique à hauteur de 110 milliards
d'euros
objectif financer les différentes aides
apportées aux entreprises des
explications de marie le bec député des
yvelines
on constate par exemple aujourd'hui que
le chômage partiel continue d'augmenter
de plus en plus d'entreprises y ont
recours est donc il faut mécaniquement
qu'on augmente l'enveloppent qui est qui
est affairé à ce chômage partiel c'est
pour que les talents restent au sein des
entreprises et que quand l'activité
économique redémarre on puisse avoir un
maximum d'entreprises qui repartent avec
leurs salariés qui sont formés et qu'il
n'y ait pas une vague de chômage et une
déperdition des compétences
on a aussi un enjeu de formation un
enjeu d'innovation qui nous permettra de
rester acteur sur la scène
internationale est je pense un enjeu de
coordination très fort au niveau
européen dans cette relance voilà un
petit peu en matière économique les
actions qu'on pourrait décider mais il
est trop tôt pour affirmer encore
exactement quel comme ça la france et
parmi ces dispositifs renforcer le fonds
de solidarité créée par l'état et les
régions pour aider les plus petites
entreprises l'île de france a renforcé
cette mesure depuis le début du mois
d'avril
écoutez alexandra dublanche vice
présidente de la région ile de france en
charge du développement économique
pelage gris contribuer à hauteur de 30 %
à peu près 80 millions d'euros que la
région mais sur ce sont pour les très
petites entreprises les commerces les
artisans qui ont connu une baisse de
chiffre d'affaires d'au moins 50%
on s'est beaucoup battu pour que ce
chiffre de 50% soit considérée par 70 %
comme au départ donc à une première
vague l'assaillait de deux demandes
satisfaites d'ailleurs j'encourage
vraiment les yvelinois continuer à
postuler jusqu'au 30 avril à tête
première vague du fonds de solidarité
parce que l'on pourrait faire un petit
peu mieux je pense vu les difficultés
vous pouvez toucher dans ces cas-là un
chèque qui va jusqu'à 1500 euros
et donc là les régions vont se charger
de la deuxième vague de ce fonds de
solidarité où on peut aller jusqu'à des
montants un peu plus élevée jusqu'à 2000
euros voire 5000 euros et prendre en
charge une partie des loyers dans des
cas très précis tu autres mesures de
soutien aux entreprises le prêt garanti
par l'état 300 milliards d'euros
débloqués pour faciliter le recours au
crédit pour les entreprises des crédits
pour lesquelles la banque publique
d'investissement se porte garant au nom
de l'état français philippe moreau
directeur du centre d'affaires bnp
paribas de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
explique les démarches à engager pour
une entreprise le chêne entreprise
contacter sa banque pour dire bah voila
j'ai un besoin de trésorerie à court
moyen terme et nous on est là pour les
appuyer en disant voilà quel peut être
le scénario un petit peu catastrophe
prenons l'hypothèse la plus pessimiste
la ré ouverture tardive
il parlait de confinement qui se
prolongent faut quand même l'avoir en
tête deuxièmement qu'est-ce que vous
avez encore en fournisseur a payé il va
bien falloir payer un jour ses charges
sociales ces charges fiscales et puis
aussi un autre sujet qu'on commence à
travailler c'est quand il va falloir
redémarrer l'activité de quoi allez vous
avoir besoin et les entreprises qui ont
besoin de recréer du stock appartements
ont aussi mis d'accord entre clients et
nous surnommons tant qu'on peut financer
le client va sur le site de l'abbaye
qu'un site extrêmement bien fait il y
voit là la bnp paribas est prête à me
prêter temps de milliers d'euros voilà
le crès école c'était générale le 6 7
ans de mon temps la bpi délivre un
numéro d'accord que le client nous
communique à partir de ce moment là on
lui envoie une offre de prêt en pdf
il ne l'a retourné en quelques jours
l'argent est crédité c'est la fin de ce
numéro merci de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez revoir cette émission en replay
sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]